I really think creativity is important
whether whatever you do I think it's fun
to be creative I think what is great
about life is being immersed in
diversity is being surrounded by people
that are not like you when you're doing
one thing figure out how to do it as
effectively as possible need motivation
watch a top ten with believe nation
what's up at seven my one where it is
believed and I believe in you I believe
you have an amazing gift inside you that
I want to see exploded onto the world so
let's get your motivation to attend and
get you believing in you grab a snack on
chewing today's lessons from a man who
went from being a kid who loves showing
off his magic tricks and performing in a
Wizard of Oz play production at age
three to becoming one of the most
influential people in the world
according to Time magazine and having a
star on the Hollywood Walk of Fame he's
Neil Patrick Harris and here's my take
on his top ten rules of success enjoy
alright let's kick things off with rule
number one my personal favorite be
patient this industry is like surfing is
that you have to get on a surfboard and
paddle paddle through and wait for a
long time hoping that you catch a wave
and you'll try and catch them and you'll
miss them and someone else will catch
them and they'll everyone will cheer and
eventually you'll catch a wave and
you'll ride it and it'll be fantastic
and you'll be really great and you'll
get all the way to the end and then the
wave will inevitably crash and you'll
have to turn around and you'll have to
paddle back out and you'll have to get
hit by waves as you get back out there
and then once you get out there you're
gonna have to sit around there for a
long time waiting for another wave to
come along but the way that surfing
works is that there are always sets of
waves that will always come up come
through and that the goal is to be
patient enough to value that metaphor
rule number two be creative and
authentic I really think creativity is
important whether whatever you do I
think it's fun to be creative with meals
that you cook or meals that you eat or
vacations that you go on or dates that
you set you know I just think it's fun
to be creative everyone likes that and I
think authenticity is just super
important I might be hyper aware of it
because I grew up in an industry that's
wrought with inauthenticity that people
will look you right in the face and and
totally tell you what you need to hear
at the moment I don't think that's
unique to that industry but it's filled
with it there so I I think transparency
and authenticity is just super important
I don't mind having conflict with
someone if we can then be done with it
it's that years spent where you know
that something's going on and you're not
talking about it those awful
Thanksgivings with the family of cousins
or you're like hey Jim hey Neela
I hate that I hate that life's too short
for that stuff rule number three think
like a magician you've actually said
quote I'm a magician at heart I think
things through I'm a games in theory guy
and I and I sort of ponder options
before I make decisions hmm so I'm less
the act from my heart guy and just sort
of say what I'm thinking and instance
tens column turn internalize a bit and
try and imagine like a chess game the
possible outcomes and then act
accordingly to what I think might be the
best and I think that goes sort of with
what a magician thinks through as well
right
like a stage magician has to keep two
steps ahead and look over here look over
here while something else is going on
over here or close-up magician it's got
to be very aware of outs and options so
I guess a magician that heart would
probably be that I sort of think like a
magician rule number four do different
things one of the things I admire most
about you is that uh you're multifaceted
and you're a true entertainer so if you
want someone who's seen dance write
produce host act we've seen you do it
all man thanks bro and you don't see
that bad often yeah I've sensed that
show even before I've been working for a
long time so I've been very interested
in not being known for doing one
singular thing and maybe that happened
because of Doogie and being in that
bubble for four years but I've missed
it's exciting to be able to be a host to
be able to be on series of unfortunate
events on Netflix in prosthetic makeup
to be able to be within a David Fincher
movie to get to do How I Met Your Mother
I've gotten to do a lot of random unique
things which is fun I like the breadth
of it rule number five be immersed in
diversity I think what is great about
life is being immersed in diversity is
being surrounded by people that are not
like you so that you can find your place
and who your own identity in your own
individuality around all kinds of other
opportunities I'm from New Mexico from a
small town I was born in Albuquerque and
lived in a much smaller
down but I got to be in rent the musical
which was that diverse world and so I
got to live with these people here
nothing like me and we're so empowering
and just so great that it made me
realize I didn't want to just spend my
time thinking in a puritanical way that
this is the only way it can be and this
is the only way that it has to yeah you
have a vast open mind
no just raising kids here you see that
on the subway and in the park you just
interact with people and that's what's
fun about it whether it doesn't matter
where they're from or who they are yeah
rule number six perform under pressure
your mother said which I thought was a
great observation that you weren't so
big on practicing as I mentioned but
when it came time for a recital hmm you
were on that some people choke under
pressure she sawing you immediately that
when the lights came on and you were
gonna do a recital you were a hundred
percent there yeah I value that I think
III appreciate the uniqueness of that
idea and yet as a as a parent I feel
like that's human nature a little bit
right like that's the worst feeling it's
not so bad to fail at your piano
concerto if you're in front of your
teacher mm-hmm but it was really it's in
front of 75 parents who then you know
are passing negative energy or judgment
that you so even at that early age I
knew when it was game time you had to
represent rule number seven be as
effective as possible how do you kind of
balance your passion for TV and film
versus musical theater because I find
that it's very hard to pursue both at
the same time I feel like I've been very
fortunate to be able to dabble in a lot
of it and I think maybe because I
started so young and I did a singular
thing and was worried that I would
therefore not get to do other things
I've had it maybe an extra drive to make
sure that I was able to do other things
and I don't mean able to do other things
been able to learn how to do other
things because each of those are such
different skills right I don't know I
think the fun thing is to be able to
when you're doing one thing figure out
how to do it as effectively as possible
so that if you are lucky enough to get
the shot to do it the chance to do it
again you've learned stuff from it and
maybe try and incorporate one into the
other I've gotten to do musical stuff on
film and I've gotten to do kind of
filmic work on the in theater so I've
been very fortunate rule number eight
honor the work of others as the actor
they bring you onto set and they say
okay quiet everyone the actors are off
set and they make everywhere the crew
has to leave and then the actors
rehearse and quietly and then then when
you're ready then they bring the crew in
and then they show the scene and then
they want you to leave and then they
actually get to work then are the 40
people who have or incredibly talented
and skilled at what they do
moving setting lights adjusting things
building tracks sure fixing painting all
that all the people that work get to
work and the actor people wander to the
craft service table told to go to their
motor home and sit and read a book and
then a knock comes on the door they're
ready for you and I thank you I'll be
five minutes and then instead of waiting
and then you come out and I don't know
it's a weird Upstairs Downstairs vibe
but I don't like it yeah and I said to
him I said I like to work I love being I
love honoring that everyone's working
together it's one of my favorite things
about being in theater it's a little bit
strange for me as an actor to to be
treated as if I'm on some other weird
level
rule number nine have role models I say
if I like Walt Disney too much then I
sort of feel like I have to defend him
because you know he wasn't was wasn't
perfect he wasn't perfect right but I
what I do admire about him is his
tenacity and his desire to create these
experiences that people seek out for the
sole experience of enjoyment with their
family and Disneyland was a place I went
to a lot when we were growing up once a
year and just the dedication to detail
and the cost spent and the number of
times that he tried to get
[Music]
money from banks to fund it and the the
amount of times he got refused and that
he still was committed to that and then
when you see it now and you still ride
Pirates of the Caribbean and you can
still see the thumbprint of what he did
that it's smart and it's childish and
it's magnificent I love that and Jim
Henson in a similar way you know he
would take inanimate objects and create
life in them that that made children
want to learn the alphabet and I think
that's amazing
and rule number ten the last one before
some very special bonus clips do magic
Oh is he a trek yes I do
okay so I love this is a deck of cards
these are actually playing card you can
buy there's no packed cars playing cards
they're all and the money goes to a read
a great theory 11.com um all different
cards I'm gonna flip through the deck
riffle through the deck and you say stop
look at the car huh I'm gonna show the
camera I'm gonna see it god I see it
because it's already click that already
Kirk one quick I'm gonna do a crazy
awesome shuffle that I just learned how
to do wait wait but I just learned hold
on it's a one-handed shuffle hold on I'm
not buying this at all what was your
card the one you're gonna show me no it
was the cards really those four clubs
four of clubs
yeah four Club correct
this is a better trick I was just
talking my cards this is a wish list
that I made a different things that I
want for Christmas mm-hmm the mph
holiday wish list of 2017 inside there's
a robot dog dying to have a robot dog
there's uh Nick Jonas headphones Nick
Jonas there's a whole bunch of things
lightsabers so here's what I want you to
do I want you to pick something in this
I have made a prediction over here I in
a box so hold out your hand
okay and I'm gonna set this here okay
lift it up a little bit higher and pull
it closer to you because what I'm gonna
do is I want you to riffle through and
I'm look at me and when you think you
are on the right page I want you to just
stop okay all right so riffle through
okay well I can't look at you me until
you think you're on a page that you like
then stop whenever you think and then
glance the page okay okay and then
perfect I've made now I'm gonna make it
suspenseful and I'm gonna ask you some
to give me some hints as to what this is
is does this thing that you I want even
have a cover it should papa
but this thing is not live the cover
it's what's it's what's more inside the
cover yes papa
and is this something that everyone can
enjoy children could enjoy this as well
yes papa they should be supervised but
yes papa
okay this box has been sitting here this
entire time for the first time will you
say will you let everyone know and we
haven't planned this no will you let
everyone know what it was that you
picked hot tub yes hot tub I have my
book by magic misfit in the box Ellen
but you said it wasn't the cover it was
what was I said was in the cover wait a
second I figured this out
and the board of
right
[Applause]
now I've got two very special bonus
clips for you from Neil Patrick Harris
on how to hustle and how to commit fully
but before that I want to get to your
commitment of the day you watch this
video don't just watch another video
make a commitment to make your life or
business better somehow I want you to
leave it down to the comments what did
you learn from this and what is your
commitment of the day to improve put it
down the council below be held publicly
accountable and I'm excited to see what
you have to say thank you guys so much
for watching I believe in you
I hope continue to believe in yourself
and whatever you're one where it is much
love I'll see you soon and enjoy the
bonus clips
we all root for you you know every time
we see you is booked obviously it's
because you're working and everybody I
think in the back of their minds like
yeah and you know get them get them
doesn't matter if you're hosting I just
want to show or whatever but I'm just
trying to figure out how do you have
time like to do all of this stuff like
you work in you're doing a Netflix show
you're a dad you're mad like how do you
have time how do I have a production
company called prediction productions
and there's three of us that work there
and I don't know it's been it's been
great we come up with a lot of good
ideas and then you see what sticks and
if something sticks normally something
like this would have a we came up with
the idea maybe three years ago and then
by the time we get serious about it to
year a year has passed so that two years
ago and then you go pitch the idea they
like it then you bring on an editor you
start you know just it's a long process
so I guess what I'm having to do sort of
Tetris style candy crush style is figure
out just when I can manage timewise the
hardest part is being filming in
Vancouver which on the west coast and
living in Harlem for the family because
I'm work you know that's a lot of
red-eye flights because I missed the
kids and they're there at the age where
you want to be able to be with them as
much as possible but I'm working full
tilt 16-hour days with make prosthetics
all over my face way far away my lunch
is there bedtime so that's a little bit
daunting you may be used to see Neil
Patrick Harris like this or this but how
about this
yeah goodbye Barney Stinson hello
fishnets Harris is now starring on
Broadway in the revival of Hedwig and
the Angry Inch the conceit of this show
is that it's only one performance and
that had biggest following Tommy noses
around everywhere he goes and so she's
taken over this theatre for just the
night so there needs to feel a sense of
unbridled explosiveness and through that
being asked a channel Iggy Pop and when
he did it he was like high on heroin and
there's all kinds of shots but that
physicality is important and so I've
just tried to be as preventative and and
pre-emptive as possible I did a stint as
the emcee in cabaret and it's its last
its first go-round
and had to leave the show a couple weeks
early because I stomped around in those
combat boots so much I got stress
fractures on all my toes so I didn't
want that to happen in the heels because
I didn't want to be aggressive and too
aggressive and then I don't have an
understudy in the show so I have to do
it whether I'm well or not so so I've
just been very conscious of being I have
physical therapy twice a week for a long
time on my feet nothing's wrong with
them now but that's the that's the point
and vocal lessons specific vocal lessons
into a microphone instead of out to a
massive audience because that's what I'm
doing but within it I'm just getting
beat up all of all the time I mean every
show is different intentionally and I'm
a little masochistic in that regard
because I don't want to just feel like
I'm doing the same thrashy movements
because then it starts to feel like
choreography to me so I'll just jump up
and throw on myself on the ground
which I did last night and my legs
started bleeding and so that I'm trying
to do a dramatic song after that I can
hear the whole front three rows going
explain
but that's that's you know that's the
excitement of it so I'm you know you
have to give it all and yet protect
yourself and I don't know what that what
that exact dynamic is but but you don't
want to feel as if you're doing a
protected performance because I think
people can sniff that out pretty quick
[Music]
the most important word ever if you had
to think of one word that's most
important to you that sums you Apple so
it would be like a little beacon pay
believe nation if you want to know what
the most important one word is for Tony
Robbins
Gary Vaynerchuk Oprah Winfrey will.i.am
and Howard Schultz I have a very special
secret video for you check the
description for details
[Music]